- [Narrator] China is reopening again
after years of COVID-19 restrictions.
The country also announced
it will drop quarantine requirements
for international travelers.
- This reopening for China has been
the biggest step they've taken
after almost three years of isolation.
- [Narrator] In response, the US
and several other countries want travelers
from China to show a negative
COVID-19 test before entering.
That's because China is facing
a huge wave of infections.
Hospitals are overcrowded
and major outbreaks
are spreading across the country.
So, three years into the pandemic,
we'll see a return of travel restrictions.
Here's what that means.
China has largely been
isolated from the rest
of the world since 2020,
(Protestors chanting in Chinese)
but following nationwide protests
and a steep economic slide,
Beijing removed almost all
of its testing, lockdown,
and quarantine measures,
including on international travel.
Starting January 8th, people traveling
to China will only need to
provide a negative COVID-19 test
within 48 hours of arrival.
- This is a big change
from the last couple
of years when it's been 14,
or 21 days even, of mandatory
centralized quarantine.
- [Narrator] But COVID-19
cases began to surge soon
after restrictions were
lifted and many pharmacies
in major cities ran low on medication.
Scientists say it's easy
for existing variants
of the virus, like
Omicron, to spread quickly
in a place where few people
had been previously infected.
- We've seen the virus
spread like wildfire
across the country.
You're seeing hospitals
often get inundated
with COVID patients,
particularly the elderly,
and then, you are also seeing,
like, factory owners complaining
because many of their workers
have been sick with COVID
and it spread so quickly
that it very often is like 30
or 40% of their workforce out at one time.
- [Narrator] For travelers from China,
that means new challenges when
flying to other countries.
The US, India, Italy, and Japan were some
of the countries that immediately
imposed new restrictions
for incoming travelers from China.
US health officials said China
was providing limited data on the surge.
- [Liza] I think what governments
and also other health officials
are concerned about is
that China might not be able
to control the spread of COVID
and from there, there
might be new variants.
- After reintroducing
COVID testing on arrival,
Italian officials said more
than half of the passengers
on one of the first flights
from China tested positive.
The Prime Minister wants mandatory tests
across the European Union.
(Giorgia speaking Italian)
China has responded by
calling for other countries
to prioritize the economic
benefits of travel.
(Wang speaking Chinese)
While countries continue to
monitor for developments,
more restrictions may be
in store for travelers coming from China.
- I think these travel
restrictions are a road bump,
but not a wall, because
people have been locked down
in China for almost three years.
There's a huge pent up
demand for travel globally.
A day after, China said
that they would lift
the border restrictions.
We saw trip.com, which is a
huge travel provider in China.
They were saying outbound
travel bookings were up
almost 300% because there
was so much pent up demand.
I just don't see it as a
very big restriction at all.